now let me give you a slightly more
interesting one and one where it's not
just harder but it's it's interesting in
that we have to make some choices as we
go about solving this question so uh Mrs
IELTS actually I found this example
following up your question last time
about you know can we call them R1 and
R2 when we got a couple others I found a
place where the textbook does exactly
that right so here are two lines on the
right hand side and our question is
determine if R1 and R2 meet at right
angles okay so that's that's the
question that's been posed to us okay
now in two Dimensions uh what would we
do with a question like this if I gave
you two lines
um and I asked you do they meet at right
angles what would you do in two
dimensions
yeah you just have a look at the
gradients right now in this context oh
and then sorry I should ask what would
you do with the gradients
yeah a good one yep you want the product
to be equal to negative one right and
that's fine okay what you're answering
in this case is the outright angles part
yeah because if they are perpendicular
then we know their gradients relate in a
certain way now in the same way uh or in
a similar way there's something that we
do for this question right to work out
whether two vectors are at right angles
to each other whether they're orthogonal
we're not going to use gradients for a
start because
um we don't have a gradient what do we
have what's equivalent to the gradient
in this
uh the what's it called again
one starts with pay one starts with the
date
the direction it's the yeah it's the
direction Vector is equivalent to
gradient in this context right so you
can
um all see the direction vectors over
here on the right hand side
um they are the part we're going to be
looking at we're not going to take them
and
um get a product of negative one what
are we looking for if they are at right
angles what should the director
Direction vectors how should they be
related
dot products should be the money degrees
yeah it should be zero very good so
um and I'm I'm gonna call this like oh
sorry wrong uh thing there I'm going to
call this Vector a and this Vector B so
what we want is uh a dot b should equal
zero if if it is true that um they're at
right angles okay now that is totally
sufficient in in two Dimensions okay
just just do the gradients they multiply
to negative one or they don't and you're
done okay however in three dimensions
this isn't enough I actually don't have
enough information to answer the
question appropriately can anyone tell
me what's missing in three dimensions
rather than in two there's an extra
thing I have to do
they could like be over the top of each
other never actually done yeah very good
so you can still have two lines that are
orthogonal like here up here my my hair
my arms are orthogonal to each other
right but they don't they don't meet
they don't intersect we had a name for
this by the way I just very briefly
mentioned it last time it starts with an
S does anyone remember
yeah so so these can be skew Lions
they're orthogonal but they don't
intersect they don't meet okay now can
you guys tell me why don't I have to ask
this question in two dimensions
because there's no there's no other sort
of like I guess playing that you could
like move off on it's always yes in
parallel yeah very good so in two
Dimensions everything's on the one plane
and so if you're not parallel you've got
to intersect somewhere right
um however that's not true in three
dimensions you can miss all the time
which is a really good thing for planes
and air control Towers like thank
goodness things can miss in three
dimensions and so what we actually need
to do as a secondary thing is we have to
talk about do the Lions meet right now
what we're going to have to do here
is we are going to well do you remember
we actually did one of these last time
right we are going to have to try and
find
a point of intersection right
we will either find a point of
intersection or we won't
and so this is what is going to tell us
um firstly whether they meet and then
secondly at right angles okay so these
are the two things we've got to do and
that gives us now or it presents to us a
choice right
um I have to do these I have to meet
these two conditions so my question to
all of you is which condition should I
try to meet first
because one of these things is easier to
work out than the other and it would
feel really silly to do the hard one
first go through all of this work and
it's like yeah cool and then we find out
the other one doesn't work and so there
was kind of no point doing all that work
so out of these two things final point
of intersection or working out a DOT
product which would you think is easier
yeah
yeah absolutely absolutely yes so
finding the dot product is absolutely
faster
um you know it's worth mentioning if
they said prove that R1 and R2 meet at
right angles it's like well okay I
already know ahead of time that I'm
going to get the right answer so it
doesn't matter which order right but in
this case it says determine so I don't
actually know and they will equally give
you questions where they do and they
don't so in this case let's do the dot
product first
so I'm even gonna write for myself dot
product
and it is true this is pretty easy to
work out so I'm just going to look at A
and B my direction vectors and I'm just
going to write them down so I've got oh
sorry the first one is positive 1
negative one and two
dot uh what have we got here 3 negative
one negative two okay what do we get
so multiplying across can you tell me
what three values I get
get three I oh no just very sorry yeah
three plus one one is four very good and
you can see are like oh okay great this
is zero so this is worth pursuing that
was very little effort thank goodness so
at this point I would say therefore R1
is orthogonal to R2 so now the rest of
the effort is actually worth it
um I'm going to now go ahead and work
out a point of intersection okay
so this is my secondary part obviously I
didn't even need to do this if I found
out that the lines were not orthogonal
but now I can proceed okay so can you
help me remember now the position Vector
which we ignored before it is important
what am I going to do to find a point of
intersection if there is one
you let the equations apply yeah
fantastic so I'm going to equate the
components and I do like to write that
um if they're just two words they don't
take long but what that does is it sort
of it frames and it gives meaning to all
of the equations that are flying around
right so I'm equating the components I'm
going to have an X and A Y and a z okay
so um go ahead and help me out there
maybe Ryan I'll put you on the spot can
you tell me what's the equation I get
from the X components
negative five plus three of you okay
fantastic uh Mrs Iles can you tell me
the Y equation
um negative Lambda equals two plus
negative two fantastic so I'm going to
go uh one step more I'm going to add the
zero there and then I'm going to go
minus mu those are equivalent yeah but
it's just for me to make sure I've got
all the points there and then Sean can
you finish this off with the Z equation
you're right take your time
you just go yeah it's just across here
yeah there's
Lambda
equals
negative two I'm sorry
yeah very good very good that's okay we
got there in the end so there's a lot of
um there's a lot of Greek letters flying
around so don't feel too bad so I got
into question one
in equation two and an equation three